اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نواصل معكم تغطيتنا
المباشره على قناه العربيه لتداعيات
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا ونحن ندخل
اليوم الثامن بلغت حاصله القتل الاجمالي
نحو خمسه وثلاثين الف قتيل كان لتركيا
النصيب الاكبر باكثر من 29 الفا وستمائه
وخمسه قتله وفي سوريا تم تسجيل
5300 وفاه وفق ارقام المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان مراسل العربيه في هذا السياق
مشاهدينا نقل عن السلطات التركيه قولها ان
13 مليون تركي تضرروا بشكل مباشر من
الزلزال ووصف تقديرات من الجهات التركيه
المسؤوله باعاده اعمال المناطق المنكوبه
خلال عام واحد مراسل العربيه افاد ايضا
بان منطقه نورداغ في ولايه غاز عنتاب
مدمره بالكامل ويوجد قسم كبير من السكان
بلا ماوى اتحاد الشركات والاعمال في تركيا
قدر حجم خسائر زلزال بنحو اربعه وثمانين
مليار دولار متوقعا ارتفاع عجز الموازنه
من ثلاثه في المئه فاصله خمسه الى اربعه
في المئه فاصل اربعه على الاقل
ونتابع معكم مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره
من منطقه كهرمان برعشى في تركيا حيث
تتواصل عمليه الانقاذ والبحث لليوم الثامن
على التوالي رغم الامال الضئيله في العثور
على نجينا تحت انقاض هذه المنازل التي
تدمرت بفعل الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا
وشمال غرب سوريا يوم الاثنين الماضي بشده
سبع درجات فاصله ثمانيه الحصير الاجماليه
مشاهدينا لعدد القتلى في البلدين تجاوز
كما ذكرنا قبل قليل تجاوزت الخمسه الخمسه
وثلاثين الف قتيل وفق حصيره جديده غير
نهائيه
[موسيقى]
نمشي
تشاهد هذا المخيم الان
كيف الخيم ثم بعد ذلك المساعدات هي كبيره
جدا بالاضافه ايضا في المقلب الاخر من هذا
المخيم هنالك مطعم كبير يستوعب الالاف
يوميا من الاشخاص يقدم لهم الوجبات
الساخنه ويقدم لهم المشروب الساخن كما
يقدم لهم ايضا بعض
اللوحات الترفيهيه للنشاطات اللاصفيه
للاطفال كالغناء وايضا الرسم على الورق في
المقلب الاخر بالاضافه ايضا الى ان هنالك
تجمع كبير لكل ما ياتي من الشاحنات
المحمله بالمواد الغذائيه او بالمواد
التموينيه او بالبطانيات او بالحرامات
بالاضافه ايضا كما اشرت الى مركز طبي داخل
هذا المركز يقدم المعونات الطبيه لمن
يريدها ان كانت طبابه في امراض عاديه ولكن
الحالات الصعبه هو لا يقدمها وايضا هذا
المركز تحول في بعض جوانبه الى مخيمه
للعمال الذين هم في الاصل من عمال المناجم
الذين اتت بهم الحكومه للمشاركه في عمليات
رفع الاوقات لما لهم من خبره في ذلك مخيم
كبير جدا كانت له
له الفضل الاكبر في الايام الاولى لاواء
عشرات الالاف
من الاتراك ثم بدا بعد ذلك بدات الامور
تخف به لان عمليه التوزيع الناس الى
المناطق الاخرى او ايضا الى
بلدات اخرى او الى محافظات اخرى هو ما يتم
وهو ما تم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا بمنطقه في غازي عنتاب
زيدان العربيه اهلا بك زيدان وما هي ابرز
ملامح اليوم الثاني من اليوم الثاني من
هذه الكارثه في غاز عنتاب
نعم اعمال الانقاذ والبحث عن ناجين ما
زالت مستمره في بعض المواقع في غازي عنتاب
لم تتوقف هذه الاعمال في المواقع التي
تعتقد فرق الانقاذ ان هناك اشخاص ما زالوا
تحت الانقاض في مواقع اخرى
مواقع تاكدت باقي انقاذ من عدم وجود اشخاص
تحت الانقاض انتهت عمليات البحث
وبدات الجرافات الكبيره بازاله الركام
وتنظيف المنطقه يعني الموضوع مرتبط حاليا
بالمعلومات المتوفره فيما اذا كان هناك
اشخاص عالقين تحت الانقاض سواء كانوا
احياء او فارقوا الحياه في هذه الحالات
تستمر عمليات البحث والانقاذ في حال لم
يكن هناك اي معلومات يتم ترك الموقع
والانتقال الى مواقع اخرى تاتي فيها ايضا
تفاصيل او معلومات عن اشخاص ما زالوا
عالقين وتقوم الجرافات الكبيره بازاله
الانقاض هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى طبعا
غالبيه سكان هذه المناطق هنا في النوردا
هم خارج طبعا هم في مخيمات او اماكن ايواء
مؤقته لا يعني كما تعلمون ان هذه البلده
ضربها الزلزال بقوه وحجم الدمار فيها كبير
جدا يعني هناك كما تشاهدون في الخلفيه
دمار كبير جدا هذا الحي تقريبا مدمر
بالكامل اتى الزلزال عليه بالكامل وسوي في
الارض لم يبقى سوى هذا المنزل او هذا
البناء المائل وطبعا بطبيعه الحال هو هدم
لكن
سيتم ازالته قريبا يعني ازاله كل هذا
المبنى هدمه بشكل كامل وايضا
ازاله الانقاض من هذه من هذه المنطقه
بالكامل تمهيدا بدء اعاده الاعمار في هذه
الاثناء سكان هذه الاماكن وسكان الابنيه
التي تصدعت وعددها كبير في نوردا يسكنون
في هذه المخيمات هذا المخيم الذي نشاهده
الان الليله الماضيه او يوم امس بدات
السلطات هنا وهيئه والكوارث افاد انشات
هذا المخيم في هذه الساحه القريبه من هذا
الدمار في محاوله لاستيعاب اعداد اضافيه
من الاشخاص او الاهالي الذين لا يملكون
ماوى في هذه
المنطقه طبعا في هذا المخيم يقدمون
المساعدات لسكان مخيم وجميع الخيام التي
نشاهدها هنا هي تابعه للهلال الاحمر وايضا
زمني لتواجد هؤلاء الاهالي في هذا المخيم
ام سيتم التوجه بهم كما وعد التركي الى
فنادق في مناطق اخرى امنه
نعم حتى الان الموضوع يعني مرتبط بجدول لا
يوجد جدول زمني معين انما يتم
اجلاء السكان من هنا تباعا الى مناطق اخرى
لكن حتى نقترب اكثر من المشهد
ونكون على صله مع الاشخاص الموجودين هنا
سالتقي عبد الرزاق وهو لاجئ سوري مقيم هنا
في
نورداغ كان مقيما هنا عند حدوث الزلزال
ومنذ سنوات طويله حسب ما اخبرتني مرحبا
عبد الرزاق اول شيء الحمد لله على السلامه
الله يسلمك انا بس حابب اطمن
فقدت حدا من العائله او يعني ان شاء الله
ما في اضرار اول شيء جسديه قبل ما نحكي
بالاضرار الماديه والله الحمد لله على كل
حال فقدت اختي وابنها وسهري مكسور ايده من
طرفين ضله شي 12 14 شهر تحت البناء
الله يرحمهم يعني بصراحه خبر مؤسف الله
يرحمه يعني ونتمنى يعني نكون قلوبنا معكم
حقيقه نتمنى يعني هيك الله يلهمكم الصبر
بس انت عم تقبلني انت انقذتهم كيف قدرت
انقذهم لانه اول ما ساعه اربعه
زلزال خفيف ثاني شيء بلش زلزال كبير طولت
شي اربع دقائق اربع دقائق
اول ما طلعت هل البنايه تحت هاي البنايه
بيجي شي خمسين واحد فيها على الارض نحن
جمعنا بعضنا حالنا وجينا لهون تغريد اتصلت
على السهري ما ردوا علي اتصلت فيه ما ردوا
علي رحنا لهنيك انه شفنا البيت واقف عليهم
عيطنا لهم عيطنا لهم سهري بس كان
عم يحكي
ضلينا شي 14 15 شهر لجبنه جرافتين كبار
لحتى طالعناهم بالزور
مباشره ابنه كان متوفي جبناه على البيت
ابنه صار يفتح عينه دغري اخذناه على
المشفى
خمس دقايق بالمشفى طوي كمان توفى يعني
طلعناه من تحت الانقاذ كان متوفي جبناه
على البيت فتح عينه دغري اخذناه على
المشفى بسيارتي صحافهن وقفناها
يعني حقيقه يعني الباقيه بحياتكم مصائب
الجمله نتمنى لكم الصبر والله يعطيكم
الصحه والقوه بس انا لا حابب تحكي لي عن
وضعك هون بالمخيم حضرتك مقيم او اخدت خيمه
عن جديد حسب ما خبرنا اخدت قيمه مبارح
بالليل
طول نهارين كنا تحت المطر وقاعدين هون
بالشوارع لانه كل العالم كانك بعدين رحنا
في حديقه فوق رحنا اخذنا شهاده الخمس
سكنا فيها ومباراه يجينا لهون المختار
اللي منطقه هون بيقعدوا فيه اخذنا اربع
خيام هون لخمس عيال خبروكن قديش راح تضلوا
قاعدين بالخيام ما خبرونا حسب الوعاده
بجوز ثلاثه اشهر يطول 20 شغله قال بجوز
ثلاثه اشهر مين خبرك هيك مختار المنطقه
هون لا الدوله خبرونا قال له انه مو مبين
بجوز ثلاثه شهور بجوز اسبوعين بيجوا ثلاثه
اسابيع بحسب
حتى الان الوضع غير معروف اسبوع اسبوعين
او ممكن نوصل لحد اقصى ثلاثه شهور
نحن ان شاء الله بنتمنى انه الموضوع يتم
بسرعه لكن بدي اسالك نقطه اخيره ما رح
اطول عليك كيف وضع المساعدات ان شاء الله
مرتاحين ما عم ينقص عليكم شيء لا
وضعتنا بس في عالم كثير عم تشتكي من
الخيام ما عم يوصلهم ثلاث ارباع العالم
نايمه بالشارع
في كتير عالم برا لسا اهم شي خيام في عالم
كثير
فعلا هي ازمه حقيقيه موضوع الخيم هذه
السيده ونحن على الهواء مباشره
والله العظيم اركض وراهم مثل الكلب الله
يعزك ما ودي غير اني مرضان وعايز
ودي خيمه قوي بنتي وقوي
غير خيمه احنا عارفة يا ابني اربعه
وين كنتوا قاعدين
بيتكم ان شاء الله ما اتاثر
على بيوت ما هو ممنوع ممنوع اساسا
هاي الظروف يعني حقيقه يعني الاوضاع صعبه
عند الجميع
والله حد صار لي يومين ما اكل معك ما اقدر
اكل نايمين بالبرد
عظامي وقع اقوم وانتم وقعت ما تعتردي ما
جوز بنتي
جوز بنتي ولاد بنتي اربعه دراهم بنايتهم
ظلوا ثلاثه ايام لطلعوهم
والله العظيم
الباقيه بحياتكم حقيقه نتمنى توصلكم
للمساعدات بشكل
عم نحاول نوصل مساعدات مساعدات
الحمد لله على السلامه الله يسلمك قديش
صار لك هون
ونسالني يعني بتركيا 12 سنه وايد 13 يعني
من اول
الحوادث الاحدث طيب بيتك تاثر بالزلزال
والله مشغل مشغل يعني
تتكسر كله للبراد التلفزيون كله نزل حاليا
ما عندكم خيمه
لاصلكم أربع زوجتك
يعني ما في غير اي كلمه ممكن توصف حقيقه
المعاناه اللي انتم موجودين فيها نتمنى
بسرعه يعني وان شاء الله صوتكم يوصل على
عبر شاشه العربيه حتى توصلكم خيمه بشكل
عاجل نحن بصريح صراحه
وين هاي الصاله الصاله هيك مغرب مغربي قام
المقام قعدت بالصاله من يوم الزلزال تحت
المطر كيف وضع الصالون
اقول لك والله العظيم مو انت من البرد متى
من الجوع من العرق
الكثير بس
منال هالشيطه ستار بس كتير خير الله كثير
بس منا خيمه في نقص بالخيام بس في معونات
كتير في كتير كتير كتير
[موسيقى]
يا ابني امبارح جينا بالليل بركنا معه
اي والله والله العظيم بس
بس معليش
بالتاكيد هناك الكثير من القصص الماساويه
والروايات المؤلمه التي يمكن ان يرويها
الناجون من هذه الماساه نتمنى بالتاكيد
زيدان ان تصل اصواتهم
للمسؤولين واصحاب القرار
سنكتفي بهذا القدر شكرا لك من منطقه
نورداغ في غازي عنتاب وانت نعم
شكرا شكرا
مشاهدينا متابعي هذه الصور من منطقه
كهرمان مرعش في تركيا حيث تتواصل عمليات
الانقاذ والبحث اليوم الثامن على التوالي
رغم الاعمال الضئيله في العثور على ناجين
تحت انقاض هذه المنازل التي تدمرت التي
ضربها جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا نذكر
مشاهدينا بان السلطات التركيه وعلى لسان
نائب الرئيس التركي اعلنت ارتفاع عدد
القتلى الى تسعه وعشرين الفا وستمائه قتيل
في تركيا وحدها وعدت الجرحى ايضا تجاوز
الاربعه بل تجاوز الثمانين الف جريح بحسب
وزير الصحه التركي
العربيه ايضا مشاهدينا اكد تضروره ثلاثه
عشر مليون تركي بشكل مباشر من الزلزال
ونائب الرئيس التركي اكد ايضا استمرار
عمليات الانقاذ بمشاركه
34,000 فرد يواصلون اعمال البحث والانقاذ
واكد ايضا ان الامل ما زال قائما في
العثور على ناجين لكن السلطه التركيه ايضا
مشاهدينا لم تخفي تخوفها من احتمالات
انتشار الاوبئه او اكد انها تتخذ تدابير
للوقايه من ذلك ومواجهه ذلك ايضا
في تركيا مشاهدينا ماساه من نوع غير مسبوق
اطفال بدون اسماء تم انقاذهم من تحت الارض
لكنه ياتي كثير منهم غير معروفه
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا لم يكتفي
بتدمير هذه المباني وتشريد العديد من
الاسر بل ضاعت بين ركامه عائلاته واسمائه
هؤلاء الاطفال
ماساه جديده يعيشها العشرات من الاطفال
الاتراك الذين يواجهون مصيرا غامضا بعد ان
سلبهم زلزال اسرهم واسمائهم ويضعهم ايضا
في خانه الاطفال مجهول الهويه بعد ان تم
انقاذهم من مباني منهاره في المناطق
المتضرره البعض منهم تعذر التعرف او
الاتصال بذويه والبعض الاخر بات يتيما
بدون اسم وزاره الاسره والخدمات
الاجتماعيه في تركيا اكدت ان مئات الاطفال
ممن مات اباؤهم او تعذر العثور على ذويهم
سيتم التكفل بهم في دور رعايه او لدى اسر
حاضنه لحين معرفه هوياتهم وعناوينهم
الاصليه
فيما تلقت الوزاره اكثر من 95 الف طلب
لحضانت هؤلاء الاطفال حتى الان مقابل شروط
للتبني وضعتها السلطات التركيه والتي سيتم
التفصيل فيها في المرحله المقبله يقول
مسؤول الصحه الاتراك ان المنطقه المنقوبه
في البلاد يوجد فيها حاليا اكثر من 260
طفلا مصابا لم يتمكنوا من التعرف عليهم
حتى اللحظه وقد يرتفع هذا الرقم بشكل كبير
مع الوصول الى المزيد من المناطق وظهور
حجم التشرد بشكل كامل
كشف الصور للاقمار الصناعيه نشرتها وكاله
الفضاء الروسيه روسكوزموس خطوط صدى
الناجمه عن زلزال تركيا المدمر واوضحت
الوكاله في منشور عبر تيليجرام انها تواصل
مراقبه عواقب الزلزال في جنوب شرقي تركيا
ونشرت الوكاله الروسيه صورا للمنطقه
المنكوبه قبل وبعد الزلزال المدمر حيث
تظهر في الصور اثار الصرع التي تسببت بها
الهزه الارضيه في محيط مطار هاتاي
مشاهد الدمار على مدار اسبوع من كارثه
الزلزال قاسيه قرن سوريه
تحتاج لمليارات الدولارات للوقوف مجددا من
خلال محاكاه افتراضيه سنعود بالزمن للوراء
للحظه للحظه التي نادرا ما تصدها
الكاميرات في التقرير التالي مع الزميل
حنين الشولي
انقضاء الساعات الثقيله يصبح ما بعدها
اثقل
ويصبحوا هذا المشهد حلما وماضيا في اذهان
ووجداني من عاصر الدقيقه الفارقه او اقصر
هكذا كانت المدينه قبل الكارثه واللحظه
القادمه نادرا ما توثقها عدسه اللح
ظه تنشا فيها بؤره زلزال تحت هذه الارض لا
التي اقف عليها بل في المركز على بعد
عشرات الكيلومترات وعمق ثلاثمائه كيلومتر
واكثر هنا لدرجه الزلزال الدور الاكبر هذه
هزه اولى بقوه صدق درجات او هزه ارتداديه
بقوه خمس درجات لاحقت زلزالا يفوقها قوه
في درجه على الاقل علميا الهزه اقل وطء
لكن هذا البيت
لم يصبر تداعى وانهار بحكم قدمه او سوء
معايير بنائه كارثه قد تحل بعشرات السكان
وربما بعض الماره ليسوا ارقاما بل الارواح
كانت امنه قبل ان تفاجاها الطبيعه
لكن امامك كارثه اكبر بالمقاييس والعواقب
ينظر الى دمار منزل او اثنين على انه
اضرار ضئيله وما سنوشك على محاكاته الان
نكبه عاشتها في 2010 كاليفورنيا الامريكيه
عام 89 تشيلي عامي 60 و 2010 وبقاع اخرى
وقف سكانها المحظوظون منهم امام خراب وترك
الالاف ضحايا تحت الالقاب
هذا ما حل بجنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا بعد
هذه اللحظه كل دقيقه بحساب وكل ثانيه
بنفسه هناك كانت غرفه النوم وهناك غرفه
المعيشه او المطبخ او الباب
كل ما كان اصبح ركاما يتسابق الوقت لرفعه
مع الموت والحياه الانقاذ والانقاذ
الامل والالم
[موسيقى]
يعتقل في السلطات التركيه عشرات المقاولين
الذين يشتبهوا بالمسؤوليتهم عن انهيار
المباني جراء زلزال الذي وقع اسبوع الماضي
وفي سياق متصل قال وزير العدل انه جرى منع
سفر اكثر من مئه وخمسين شخصا المسؤولين عن
تشييد مباني انهارت بفعل زلزال
لحظات انكشفت مداها شاشه المباني في
المناطق المتضرره من زلزال تركيا والسلطات
تحاول احتواء الغضب الشعبي في هذه المناطق
قوات الامن نفذت حمله اعتقالات طالت عشرات
المقاولين والمهندسين واعلن وزير العدل
التركي بكير بوزداج انشاء مكتب للتحقيق في
جرائم الزلزال وما تبعه من وفيات واصابات
كما كشف الوزير عن اعتقال 62 من مقاولي
البناء فيما قالت وكاله انباء الاناضول ان
عدد المعتقلين تجاوز المئه في المقاطعات
العشره التي طالها الزلزال
تركيا سبق لها ان شددت قوانين البناء بعد
زلزال ازميت شمال غرب البلاد عام
1999 والذي قتل فيه 17 الف شخص المعايير
التي تم تحديثها عام 2018 تستلزم استخدام
هياكل مصنوعه من خرسانه عاليه الجوده
مدعمه بقضبان فولاذيه وعلى ان توزع
الاعمده لامتصاص تاثير الزلازل بشكل فعال
لكن رغم المعايير المفروضه قدمت السلطات
اعفاءات للمباني المنشاه دون شهادات
السلامه المطلوبه على ان يتم دفع رسوم
مقابل عدم الالتزام الاعفاءات هذه لقيه
انتقادات داخليه وحذر منتقدون من ان
التهاون في قوانين البناء قد يؤدي لكارثه
حال وقوع زلزال كبير في الجانب البحري
نقلت صحيفه حريات ديلين نيوز عن استاد
جيولوجيا بجامعه اسطنبول قوله ان اختيار
اماكن البناء جرى بشكل غير علمي مست جدا
بزلزال كايكور نيوزلنديه عام 2016 الذي
بلغت قوته 7.8 درجه وادى حينها لمقتل
شخصين واصابه 57 اخرين
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ينضم الينا من اسطنبول استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور سمير صالحه
دكتور سمير معنا في هذه التغطيه وبدايه
استمرار حمله الاعتقالات هذه التي تطال
متعهدي البناء في تركيا هل هي محاوله
لاسترضاء الشارع التركي
صباح الخير للجميع اولا يعني طبعا مهمه ان
يتم اعتقاله توقيف الاشخاص الذين مولوا او
اشرفوا على مثل هذه
المشاريع التي هوى سقط
الكثير منها لكن اظن انه في المدرسه لا
تحتاج الى حمله اوسع بكثير من ذلك يعني لا
يكفي اعتقال الممول او الشخص الذي هو صاحب
صاحب المشروع لابد ايضا من المساءله
القانونيه والفنيه والتقنيه حول الذين
ساهموا وقعوا
سمحوا بانجاز هذا المشروع بهذا الشكل واظن
هذا سيفتح الطريق داخل التركي امام
النقاشات اوسع في المرحله المقبله لماذا
لانه العديد الان من الاحزاب المعارضه
تحاول فتح هذا الملف بشكل او بشكل اخر
النقطه المهمه التي اشرتم اليها انتم ايضا
قبل قليل ستحمل معها براي نقاشات جديده في
الداخل التركي مساله الاعفاء او العفو
العام عن المخالفين في مشاريع البناء وهذا
يتكرر بين الحين والاخر في الداخل التركي
ولذلك الان في اصرار على انهاء نقاش من
هذا النوع قطع الطريق على اي محاوله
يعني حتى وان تمت هذه المناقشات التي اشرت
اليها الا ترى انها جاءت متاخره عطفا على
المعلومات المسبقه بان تركيا ايضا ستتعرض
زلزال وهناك ايضا من المعلومه ان تركيا
موجود اصلا على خط الزلازل الم تاتي هذه
الخطوات بشكل متاخر
تماما اتفق معك نحن نناقش هذه المسائل في
موضوع الاعفاء منذ العام 1984 وكان في عنا
اكثر من قرار الصدر بهذا
الاتجاه يعني النعم القرار الاعفاء مهم
لكن ما الذي واكبه من اتخاذ التدابير
عمليه فنيه على الارض بتجاوز اي ازمه او
كارثه محتمله لذلك انا قلت لك قبل قليل
انه هذه النقاشات الان ستذهب باتجاه اوسع
ومتعدل الاطراف الان في عنا يعني الارقام
التي نناقشها حتى في داخل التركي لا يوجد
عنا رقم نهائي رسمي واضح حول سيناريوهات
والاحتمالات يعني عدد القتله مثلا ان عدد
رسمي معروف الان لكن العديد من التقارير
للعديد من المؤسسات الخاصه بنشر ارقام
مغايره وهذه مساله الان تغلق ايضا سواء
كان لنحت الاضرار منحه عدد القتلى الاعداد
الجرحى وغيرها من
الجديده يبدو ايضا ان الامر اكبر من ذلك
وذلك حسب المعارضه التركيه التي تقول ان
هذا زلزال سيفتح اعين الاتراك على حقائق
كبيره متعلقه بالفساد في قطاع الانشاءات
هل لنا ان نتنبا بهذه الحقائق الكبيره
يعني كما قلت لك قبل قليل في عندي اليوم
تقرير مثلا جديد مشهر
لجمعيه رجال الاعمال يتحدث عن ارقام اكبر
بكثير من الارقام الان التي نتحدث عنها
صحيح انه عمليات الانقاذ مستمره لاخراج
الناس من تحت الانقاد مستمر لكن لا نعرف
عدد الذين بقوا تحت الانقاذ هذه النقطه
الاولى نقطه ثانيه علينا ان ناخذها بعت
انه حجم الكارثه كبير جدا
في مرحله انتقاليه الان نعيشها في داخل
التركي هذه المرحله الانتقاليه فيها كما
اشرتم انتم قبل قليل في تقارير يكون فيها
الشق الاغاثي الشق الانساني الشق الشق
الصحي المعيشي الخدم يعني في عنا اكثر من
تحرك باكثر من اتجاه المساله القضاء التي
نتحدث عنها ايضا جزئيه اساسيه في كل هذه
المباشر المسائله القانونيه حول ما جرى
والاستفاده من الدروس للتحرك في المرحله
لكن سهام النقد هذه التي اطلقتها المعارضه
ايضا طالت الرئيس اردوغان باستفاده
مقاربين منه بما يتعلق بموضوع المنح التي
اشرت اليها او الاعفاءات
المتعلقه برخص الابنيه هل الرئيس اردوغان
متورط ايضا في هذه الازمه
لا اظن المساله يعني براي الشخصي انا من
خلال المت
ابعه في تركيا يعني قبل ان يصل حزب
العداله والتنميه الى السلطه ووصل عام
2002 كما تعرف قبل ايضا نقشنا هذه المسائل
وبعد هذه نقشنا هذه المسائل لكن اين هي
الان النقطه الجديده التي ستركز عليها
المعارضه انه الحزب العداله والتنميه بعد
تسلمه للسلطه انتقد هذه السياسات في موضوع
الاعفاءات
ضروره التشدد في التعامل مع مسائل البناء
ولكن راينا الان في تقارير جديده تقول انه
العديد من الامنيه الكثير من الابنيه التي
سقطت تم انشائها بعد العام 2002 وهذه نقطه
اساسيه ايضا لذلك انا قلت لك النقاشات
ستبدا وربما ايضا تحمل معها اكثر مؤشر في
المرحله المقبله نعم اذا من اسطنبول كنت
معنا استاذ العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور سمير
صالحه شكرا لك دكتور سمير
مشاهدينا نتابع معكم هذه الصور المباشره
من منطقه كهرمان مرعشلي عمال انقاذ وهم
يتواجدون يتواجدون داخل احد المباني وكما
يبدو وكانها نقاشات تدور بين هذه الفرق
حول كيفيه اتمام عمليه الانقاذ والبحث
والانتشار ايضا في هذا المبنى الذي انهار
ايضا بسبب الزلزال الكبير الذي ضرب تركيا
يوم الاثنين الماضي ضربت طبعا جنوب تركيا
وشمال غرب سوريا بشده بلغت 7 درجات فاصله
ثماني درجات الحصيه الاجماليه مشاهدينا
نذكر بها لعد القتلى حتى الان في البلدين
تجاوزت خمسه وثلاثين الف قتيل وفق حصيله
جديده غير نهائيه كما ان منظمه الصحه
العالميه اكدت ان 26 مليون شخص قد تاثروا
بهذا الزلزال في كل من سوريا وتركيا بينما
قدرت الامم المتحده ان عدد القتلى سيتجاوز
40 الفا واكدت ان مرحله الانقاذ في تركيا
اقتربت ايضا
مشاهدينا بعد نحو عام من بدء الحرب في
اوكرانيا اتفقت روسيا واوكرانيا اخيرا على
قضيه واحده وهي ضروره اغاثه المتضررين من
الزلزال المدمره الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
حيث اعلنت روسيا ارسال ثلاث طائرات تحتوي
على مساعدات انسانيه منها 500 خيمه وتسعه
الاف حقيبه نوم وحصائر عازيه للحراره
وتسعه عشر طنا من المنتجات الغذائيه من
جهتها قالت دائره الطوارئ الحكوميه
الاوكرانيه يوم الاحد قالت انه ممثليها
وعمال الانقاذ الاوكرانيين التقوا
بمسؤولين من اداره الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه افاد للتعاون بين رجال انقاذ
الاوكرانيين والاتراك
ونلتقي المشاهدين الى سوريا التي وصلت
فيها اعداد القتل الى خمسه الاف وثلاثمائه
على الاقل وفقا ما افاد المرصد السوري
وهذه الارقام مشاهدينا مرشحه للارتفاع
بسبب ضعف عمليات الانقاذ واستمرار الجدل
حيال ادخال المساعده الانسانيه الدوليه
وفيما يستعد مجلس الامن اليوم لعقد اجتماع
يبحث مساله ارسال المساعدات الى الشمال
السوري اكد المرصد للعربيه ان النظام
السوري لا يزال يمنع المساعدات الى
المناطق الادائيه الى مناطق الاداره
الذاتيه في الشمال السوري
دعت الولايات المتحده النظام وكافه
الاطراف السوريه الى تسهيل دخول المساعدات
الانسانيه لجميع المحتاجين في كافه احائل
البلاد وقال متحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
بالبيت الابيض انه يجب السماح بدخول جميع
المساعدات الانسانيه عبر جميع المعابر
الحدوديه الى سوريا ويتعين توزيع
المساعدات على جميع المناطق المتضرره دون
تاخير
افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان بان
النظام السوري لا يزال يرفض دخول قوافل
لمنظمات بينها الهلال الاحمر الكردي قادمه
من مناطق الاداره الذاتيه لشمال شرق سوريا
الى المناطق المكوبه في حلب وقال المرصد
ان القوافل الانسانيه وكوادرها من سوريين
واجانب لا تزال تنتظر منذ 48 ساعه عند
معبر التايهه منبج شرق حلب واضاف المرصد
ان النظام يشترط تسليم المساعدات له
لتوزيعها عن طريق الهلال الاحمر السوري
الكوارث لم تصطدم بخرسانات متهاويه لكنها
تخططها لترفع جدران عزله احاطت بالنظام
السوري لسنوات واعادت خلط اوراق الرئيس
التركي السياسيه
زلزال السادس من فبراير حله مدمرا قتل
وفرق وشرد لكنه اسقط حواجز وخلافات سياسيه
هيمنه على علاقات دول لحين لملمت الماساه
فازاح الدول لا ترتبط بعلاقات طيبه مع
تركيا او سوريا ملفاتها موضع الخلاف
وانضمت الى قافله المساعدين
واشنطن استعانت باستثناءات خاصه بالعمليات
الانسانيه لتعلق العقوبات المفروضه على
سوريا وتسمح بادخال المساعدات اليها
وفي وقت ارسلت فرق انقاذ لتركيا اكتفت
بتقديم المساعده لسوريا عبر شركاء محليين
لرفضها التعامل مع الاسد
اما في تركيا فانفتح الطاقات التعاون من
مختلف الجهات فالحدود مع ارمينيا فتحت
لاول مره منذ عقود لادخال المساعدات رغم
خلافات تاريخيه
الجار اليوناني تخطط توترات كادت ان تصل
لمواجهه عسكريه بسبب نزاعات على جزر
وتنقيب عن مصادر الطاقه دبلوماسيه الزلزال
شملت زياره لوزير الخارجيه اليوناني برفقه
نظيره التركي الى انطاكيا وارسال مساعدات
انسانيه وفرق اغاثه وعمال انقاذ لتحقق ما
قاله السفير التركي السابق لدى اثنا
بخطابه الوداعي تمنيات بعدم الحاجه لكوارث
او زلازل لتذكر الجيره
السويد تناست موقفه تركيا المعرقله لمسع
انضمامها لحلف شمال الاطلسي فطور
والعلاقات لم يؤخر مصر كذلك عن ارسال
مساعدات طبيه الى تركيا كما لم تؤثر
العمليه العسكريه التركيه شمال العراق في
تضمين ان بالجسر الجوي الاغاثي
هذا ولا تزال مساعدات مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه تصل الى زلزال
في شمال غرب سوريا حيث بلغ عدد الشاحنات
المحمله بالمواد الاغاثيه
عشره شاحنه حتى الان فيما بدات عمليات
التوزيع المساعدات على الاهالي المتضررين
من الزلزال في جنديرس وتركيب الخيم
لمساعده الاهالي في توفير اماكن يقيمون
فيها بعد تدمير منازلهم هذا وتستمر الحمله
السعوديه لاغاثه المتضررين من الزلزال في
استقبال التبرعات التي بلغت اكثر من 320
مليون ريال بعد سته ايام من اطلاقها
[موسيقى]
يلا بدنا الوسائل
يلا
[موسيقى]
بسم الله
نقل المساعدات عبر المعابر في سوريا
يعني حتى الان جميع المعابر الداخليه بين
مناطق النفوس المختلفه لا تزال مغلقه امام
حركه المساعدات المقدمه سواء من الجهات
الرسميه او حتى من
بعد اداره الفرديه والجماعيه حيث اقف وانا
في معبر ام جلود بين منبج وجرابلس اي بين
مناطق الاداره الذاتيه والمعارضه لا تزال
الشاحنات المحمله بالوقود موجوده هنا منذ
خمسه ايام ولم يسمع لها بالدخول الى طرف
الاخر الى
البلاد
ايضا
تحمل موارد غذائيه وانسانيه عالقه في هذا
المعبر الواصل بين مناطق الاداره الذاتيه
ونظام ايضا
منذ خمسه
ايام حتى المعابر الموجوده بين
مناطقام ومناطق المعارضه
ايه مساعدات في تطور جديد نقوم بالتاكد
منه بعض من القائمين على المبادرات
الفرديه او يعني
الشاحنات التي جمعتها منظمات المجتمع
المدني هنا في شمال شرق سوريا يقولون لنا
بانهم حصلوا على موافقه الطرف الاخر اي
طرف المعارضه السوريه بادخال هذه يعني
الشاحنات لربما خلال الساعات المقبله
سنتاكد لان التاكد لم يعد من المصادر لان
المصادر مختلفه ومتنوعه سنتاكد من
البوابات المعابر نحن على بوابه ام جلود
وسنعرف
اذا كانت هذه الشاحنات الاهليه وغير
الرسميه يسمح لها بالدخول ام لا لان هناك
الان شاحنه يعني من اطباء بلا حدود عبر
شريك محلي تقف على بعد امتار فقط من مدخل
معبر ام الجلود سوف تدخل هذه الشاحنه وفقا
معلوماتنا لنرى ان كانت سيسمح لها بالدخول
او حتى ان دخلت سيكون هناك طرف اخر غير
طرف
سيعيد هذه الشاحنه مره اخرى الى مناطق
الاداره الذاتيه يعني
هنا يخضع لعديد من التجاذرات من النظام
ومن الاكراد ومن المعارضه وفي جسم
المعارضه نفسها هناك عده اطراف يتخذون
القرار بنعم او لا لدخول هذه المساعدات او
ابقاء عالقه في هذه المعابر طيب الجمعه
ماذا على عفوا ماذا عن المساعدات التي
تاتي من اطراف خارج سوريا مثلا من الامم
المتحده هل تمر عبر هذه المعابر بسهوله هل
تتعرض لذات المضايقات او التعقيدات في
موضوع مرورها الى مناطق اخرى داخل سوريا
يعني المساعدات الامميه ترسل عبر ما عبر
باب
حصرا
في الشاحنات دخلت 52 شاحنه مقدمه من الامم
المتحده معظمها من المفوضيه الشؤون
اللاجئين والصحه العالميه دخلت من معبر
باب الهوى هناك ايضا معلومات مؤكده بانها
شاحن قافله اخرى من شاحنات
الام
طيب
جمعه اعتذر منك لان الصوت رديء جدا ويصلنا
بشكل متقطع ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر شكرا لك
من معبر ام جلود ينضم كنت معنا عفوا
ورسائل العربيه جمعه عكاش تحيات جمعه
مشاهدينا ينضموا الينا من ريف حلب اصبح في
احمد ابو لؤي اهل احمد معنا في هذا
التغطيه كما تبعنا سهام الانتقالات
والاتهامات الطالب الجميع في سوريا سواء
كان نظام او المعارضه فيما يتعلق بمنع
دخول هذه المساعدات وصولها الى مستحقها
اين تكمن الحقيقه
يعني مع الاسف الشديد اليوم موضوع
المساعدات وبسبب صراع السياسي لا اكثر ولا
اقل سواء من مناطق النظام او من الجانب
التركي او من الاكراد او من المعارضه يعني
هذا واقع لا اكثر ولا اقل يعني كما ذكر
الزميل جمعه
مساعدات من امم المتحده ايضا هنالك
مساعدات او 12 حافله دخلت من الاكراد من
مناطق
الاكراد طبعا عفوا كردستان العراق من
مؤسسه طرزاني اضافه دخل يوم امس او او قبل
يومين وحتى يوم امس يتم توزيعها مساعدات
مقدمه من قبل الجانب السعودي وهنالك وعود
تقديم منازل مؤقته او كرفانات
بعشر الاف عائله من قبل الجانب القطري
سنتجه قليلا الوضع الكارثي الراهن فبعد
اليوم اسبوع او ثمانيه ايام على كارثه
الزلزال التي ضربت شمال غربي البلاد
وطبعا اعلام فرق الدفاع المدني انتهاء
عمليات البحث قبل ايام وانقاذ العالقين
ولم يعلن الدفاع
المدني عمليات ايقاف عمليات البحث الا بعد
القطاع الامل من دخول
المساعدات تعاليات وغيرها من الاجهزه
الذكيه من اجل يعني الكشف عن العالقين حتى
لو وافقتهم المنيه طبعا بلغت احصائيه
الضحايا العامه
حاله وفاه 2950 مصابه الحيز الاكبر اخذته
مدينه جنديرس المنكوبه في ريف عفرين شمال
حلب حيث بلغ عدد الضحايا في هذه المنطقه
513 حاله وفاه طبعا تلاها حارم في ريف
ادلب 360 حاله وفاه وايضا تلقين 221 وفاق
وعدد من المناطق الاخرى طبعا اوضاع
ماساويه بشكل كبير اليوم
اليوم الخوف والهلع ولا قلق
السوريين بشمال غرب سوريا وتخوفات للعوده
من عوده الزلزال من جديد بقوته الاولى
يعني حتى الان ما زال هنا تحزات ارتداديه
والى متى ستقف
تتوقف هذه الهزاز لا احد يعلم طبعا اوضاع
ماساويه
احمد يعني بالنسبه
له والناجين يعني كيف يعيشون تفاصيل يومهم
كيف يتدبرون امورهم وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بالدواء والغذاء والايوه ايضا
نعم بالنسبه للعالقين الذين ما زالوا على
قيد الحياه فاثناء
اخراجهم من تحت الركام بشكل مباشر يتم
ارسالهم الى اقرب مركز صحي او مشفى او
مستوصف لتلقيات لتلقي العلاج طبعا غالبيه
بسبب التعويله
بماذا تحت الركام يعني غالبيه اليوم
العالقين وما زالوا على قيد الحياه خرجونا
يعني معرضين الكسور وردود وغير ذاهبه يعني
اليوم ايضا استقرار كبير من ناحيه الجانب
الصحي ايضا لم يفصل يعني معدات حديثه من
اجل تلقي العلاج
للناجين طبعا ساتكلم قليلا عن عائلات التي
شردت اليوم الاف العائلات بسبب تصدع
المباني
يعني هنالك الاف المباني التي تصضعت في
مناطق ريف او مناطق ريف ادلب طبعا هنالك
الاف العائلات اليوم نجدهم في العراء في
الاراضي الزراعيه تحت اقسام الزيتون
ولربما ايضا بعضهم ذهب الى اقربائهم
المقيمين في احواش عربيه او منازل ارضيه
عربيه التي تعتبر اشد خطورا تعرضها للهزاف
الامتداديه او الزلزال يعني اوضاع ماساويه
بكل ما تعنيها الكلمه اليوم المعاناه او
الماساه تتفاقم اليوم نجد هنالك العديد من
الاطفال سيتموا يعني ذويهم اهاليهم جميعهم
يعني بوافتهم المانيه تحت الانقاض يعني
هنالك العديد من الحالات الاطفال لم
يتجاوز اعمارهم من سنوات عشر سنوات في
المشافي وحتى الان لم يعلموهم بان
اهاليهم موافقهم المنيه من اجل الموضوع
النفسي يعني او ضع ماساويه توجد كلمات
كافيه سيد احمد يمكن ان تعبر بشكل كافي عن
حجم الماساه وحجم الضمائر الذي تعانيه
السوريون في هذه الايام
سكتفي بهذا القدر لقد اهمل الوقت اعتذر
منك جدا وشكرا جزيلا لك على كل ما تفضلت
به كنت معنا من الريف حلب الصحفي احمد ابو
لؤي تحياتي
اشهر التقارير الرسميه وامميه الى الضروري
عدد كبير من المنازل في شمال سوريا جراء
زلزال العنيف وبحسب بيان للامم المتحده
فان زلزال دمر نحو 115 مدرسه في الشمال
السوري فيما تحولت 100 مدرسه اخرى الى
مراكز ايواء لالاف وفي بلده جنديرس في حلب
قال احد المعلمين لوكاله رايترز ان مدرسه
فقدت معلمتين ونحو سبع سبعه تلاميذ وكانت
وزاره التربيه بدمشق قد اعلنت تضرر
نحوثمان واربعين مدرسه نتيجه زلزال مضيفه
ان المدارس المضطره تقع في حلب والذي قيا
وحماه وتغطوس
يشكر قطاع الصحي في مناطق شمال سوريا من
نقص المستلزمات الطبيه وضعف التمويل
لمواجهه اثار زلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
المنطقه قبل نحو اسبوع اما الكادر الطبي
فحدث ولا حرج حيث يخدم طبيب واحد عشره
الاف شخص في ظل ظروف زلزال الحاليه
[موسيقى]
للساعه اربعه العصر
جديد عن المستشفى وصار غسلتي مرتين
وهي الثالثه يمكن
[موسيقى]
نا كتير اصابات من الزلزال اصابات كانت
شديده للاسف المرضى اللي عم يطلعوا من تحت
الانقاط في عندهم كان هرس عضلي هذا الامر
انا لعبت كتير علينا لانه نحن بالاساس ما
عنا هاي المستلزمات دعارات التحالف الدموي
وهي دارات مكلفه
[موسيقى]
دانا ساون
لتصدعات كبيره تم بفضل الله عز وجل اخلاء
المرضى والكادر بالسرعه القصوى للحفاظ على
سلامتهم
[موسيقى]
قصه اخرى من ادلب اغرب خيال شاب سوري
ابلغه رجال الانقاذ بوفاه امه فراح يبكيها
كما يبكي الطفل الصغير بعد اخراجها
وبساعات تمكن مسعفون من انقاذها العين هي
العين والدموع هي الدموع لكن السبب مختلف
في الحالتين نتابع
[موسيقى]
يضل الرجل طفلا حتى تموت امه فاذا ماتت
شاخ فجاه
كثيرا حول ما قال ذلك ولكن الاختلاف حول
صدق المعنى
ادلب بعد 36 ساعه من بقاء امه تحت الانقاض
ابلغوه انها فارقت الحياه ليتحول الرجل
الذي خالط الشيب لحيته الى طفل يواجه
شعورا يطمي لاول مره
الله اكبر الله اكبر ولكن بعد ذلك بساعات
تنقلب حياته مره اخرى هذه المره للافضل
الام تم انقاذها وهي على قيد الحياه ليحصل
على فرصه اخرى فرصه لن يترك فيها ابدا
السيده التي استقبلته حينما ابصر النور
لاول مره
[موسيقى]
قولي يلا والله نحلف والله نسمع صوتك
مشاهدينا سنواصل معكم تغطيه لزلزال لكن
نتوقفوا مع بعض الاخبار الخاصه بملفات
اخرى
شن الطيران الحربي الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم
عده غارات جويه مستهدفا الموقع لحركه حماس
في غزه وقال جيش الاسرائيلي انه قصف موقعا
تحت الارض تستخدمه الحركه في تصنيع
الصواريخ بينما اكدت مصادر امنيه فلسطينيه
ان الغاره الحقت الظاهرا جسيمه في الموقع
ومحيطه دون ان تسفر عن خسائر في الارواح
قال صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه ان طهران
تستخدم قوارب وشركه الطيران مملوكه للدوله
لتهريب المسيرات الى روسيا واوضحت الصحيفه
ان ايران سلمت 18 مسيره بعيده المدى
للبحريه الروسيه مشيره الى ان الوفد
الروسيه الذي زار طهران في نوفمبر الماضي
طلب سته سيارات محمره بالصواريخ وان هذه
المسيارات كانت تصنع في المنشاه التي تم
استهدافها في اصفهان الشهر الماضي
مشاهدينا نهايه هذه الساعه من تغطيتنا
الساعه المقبله مع الزمن خالد مدخلي
[موسيقى]
حسيت انه القرصه تتحرك من تحت صارت صارت
الحجار من حوالي والعماره صارت تتحرك
صارت شوي
رجعنا فزعانين صار الحيطان تمر على
الاولاد البنايات عم تهبط على الارض
كنا بالبنايه الحيط على اخواتي بس انا
الحمد لله ما صار شيء انا واختي وطلعنا من
البنايه بعجوبه ما بعرف فيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]